l'entrée du château de cheverny les
drapeaux aux couleurs de deux pays
donnent le temps dans les deux grandes
salles deux écrans géants diffusent en
continu des images exhumé du passé une
résurrection dans mon grand-père là et
qui bouge et mon grand oncle et puis non
des jets des images on a presque on est
presque ravi qu'elle soit pas davantage
net pour qu'elle conserve ce côté
historique ce côté ce côté archives
cheverny ample et court ce dernier en
particulier eux avait des régiments
transmission et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le régiment qui défilent ce
jour là devant château est un régiment
de transmissions qui est clair qu'on
traduit en anglais donc on américain par
un signal corp
nous sommes en 1918 sur cette photo de
soldats des parents de la famille du
marquis de fibres et son grand-oncle 27
ans son grand-père 25
mon grand oncle philippe et mon
grand-père tonique vibrer là on a fait
ressortir leurs tenues bleu horizon par
les effets de la technologie moderne
pour fêter la fin de la guerre et le
retour de ses fils
la marquise de vibrer reçoit sa table
des officiers américains
c'est à partir de cette photo inédite
que constance de vie près la
reconstituer ce fameux déjeuner 2 - de
recherche patiente
j'ai essayé de retrouver dans les
greniers dans les placards tout ce que
je retrouvais sur cette photo sur la
table sur cette photo voilà et c'était
très très amusant et à la fois très
émouvant tout l époque les américains au
château de cheverny
une exposition à voir jusqu'au 8
décembre